hello everybody hope that are good first
of all thank you very much for being
here another week for listening to me
and of course we're want to talk about
this projection that I do on Sunday in
the Bitcoin suay update on X that so far
is playing out and it doesn't mean that
it's going to continue playing out but I
think it will and I'm going to explain
my reasons why and I know when I drew
this on Sunday a lot of people didn't
agree with me and that's completely fine
uh don't worry in fact um that gave me
more confidence that it was going to
play out because when all the market
agrees on one idea on on a projection
then it doesn't usually happen the
market doesn't give that away okay so um
when I saw many people disagreeing I
thought okay this definitely has had a a
possibility of playing out so so far
it's been playing out I threw this third
uh Spike higher than the previous two
simply because I was expecting this
reversal here and for that reversal to
happen then first they have to make sure
that all the current short positions
that were opening inside this area and
this area with the stop losses above the
highs were going to get hit so for that
I was expecting a third top higher that
came it happened in this area exactly
here also we got the news that Biden was
dropping out of the of this year
presidential election race and we
created this long wiek to the downside
that was also giving me more confidence
that we're want to revisit this area
here okay so when I saw this Spike here
and this was after the I posted my
projection then I thought okay
definitely this can play out then we
surprise dropping fill in that week also
in the 4 hours time frame we saw price
going towards the area that was around
here and finally it came to my area here
okay that if you notice is that why this
area well simply because there was a
couple of liquidity pools one in the 1
hour time frame that mag indicator
marked and right now has removed because
it's failed but you can see that we have
created a new one here okay but anyway
this was a liquidity pool that got
filled that's not a straight line at all
there that liquidity pool there got
filled but also in the four hour time
frame we had a very similar situation
and it was this one here okay you can
also see this very large candle body
here okay so you can see how exactly
retrace those two liquidity pools
especially the one in the 4our time
frame and the next one is really below
um that would be the next area to look
for Longs if we lose this area but I
think we might hold here but again if
price starts to drop in lower then we
have this liquidity pool matching with
the range lows that in principle should
be able to hold okay we'll explain that
later so let's go back to the one hour
time frame why was I expecting all of
this volatility well simply because we
got the news of Biden dropping out of
the presidential election race which
means that it was going to be a week of
volatility I didn't go as far as saying
if that was bullish or beish because
that's not for me to decide it's for the
market to the S side but in terms of
volatility I was going to bring a lot of
volatility so I was going for a very
ambitious and active projection as you
can see I see a lot of price movement
it's a I was literally draw drawing 5%
down 7% up okay now can this happen
still inside this week well we have only
two days because Saturday and Sunday I'm
not expecting much of a move so perhaps
it doesn't happen this week and it
continues going through next week but
also why I think that this might play
out during next week and it's something
also I answer on Sunday is that I think
that this drop here is a ShakeOut of
they're basically they're basically
shaking out the market and this is
something that I was anticipating in the
Bitcoin dat simply because the 31st of
July we have the fomc meeting okay now
the fomc meeting that is going to happen
on Wednesday of next week and I'm
expecting it to to be bullish and I'm
going to tell you why we had du
imployment rate going up we have
inflation going down and this is adding
a lot of pressure for the FED to either
qu rates which to be honest I'm not
expecting the F the FED could R this
month but what I'm expecting is that
this month the 31st of July they
announce or they hint very clearly that
on September because in August we don't
have fomc so in September's fomc meeting
they will cut the rates so I'm expecting
the 31st of July either an announcement
of that or a hint very clear that that's
what they're going to do and when that
happens then the market tends to price
that in so um I'm going ahead of the
market here I don't know if it's going
to happen or not but that's my game
theory so uh if that is the case then
the market is going to price price in
that rate C and prices are going to go
higher and we have a lot of liquidations
here now if you notice go on X check
your timeline we are in this level here
and most Traders are expecting lower
prices they're scared to go
long right so that is what is telling me
that it's likely that prices go up again
same as what happened on Sunday people
here were greedy they were expecting
8K I got some some critics for the this
drop here it happened now we're here and
people are scared that price are going
to continue going down and I'm expecting
price to reverse from here so um it's
Market psychology let's see what happens
also I'll tell you in the one or time
frame something that helps me to think
that it's likely that we see a reversal
from here actually it's two things the
first thing is if you notice we have
here so many weeks let's zoom in look at
that
so many weeks to the downside but price
is not breaking through this
area why are they spiking down inside
this Orange Box here with
Wicks and they are not bringing price
lower why are they holding this area is
it because the market maker is building
Longs at the lowest level in the
chart I mean just think about it guys
when you set weeks like this okay that
means that you are opening well if you
can open Longs here okay that will be
here here here here here here and
pushing price back up is that what it's
happening
guys well it could be okay it could be
that the market make it is building long
here um so far that will be my
conclusion right now that's what I think
um again maybe now I post the video and
after two hours price do something like
this boom but
by uh looking at what happens the
behavior of the candles literally if you
zoom out and you see what happens look
at this for example weeks to the upside
here price not breaking through why
because they were building shorts at the
highest area drop happens the same here
okay it happens the same here weeks to
the downside prices go up WS to the
downside prices go up weeks to the
downside look at this guys so many weeks
to the downside then boom price go up
okay so go to energetic there but that
is the reason number one what I think
that we might see a reversal and the
second one is sorry for all the clicking
I'm going to use the the the mouse pad
instead of the laptop the other reason
is because I always say this okay fake
move at the start of the week that when
I say at the start of the week the start
of the trading week is um from Sunday
evening to Monday evening sometimes it
comes on Sunday sometimes in comes on
Monday but usually we see a false move
at the start of the week now to me that
false move was clearly this pum here
that came after the bu the news you got
that pum there third up pattern
everybody eoric c8k then you see the
drop
here through all the week see literally
since Monday until Thursday you see the
drop and for the guys that are well have
done the course or or that right now
doing the course what happens on 30s
guys usually we see a reversal and we
have the 1 hour 50 ma here at
65,00 we also have this liquidity pool
that my indicator is marking check that
out it's matching with the one out 50a
with all these weeks here to the down of
a price now breaking through are we
getting a reversal today to
65,000 that's a $1,000 move
okay so um based on day trading that is
what I'm putting my money today right
now um let's continue I hope that that
was clear now that I'm doing instead of
a daily video I'm doing more like a
weekly video analyzing the whole uh
spectrum of time frames and and what
it's coming for next week Etc then um I
can take my time to explain um more my
reasoning so uh sorry for that H long
explanation but I think it's necessary I
think it can help somebody and um this
is what YouTube is for in my case
because on on X I have charact I have
limitation on characters I don't have my
voice to express myself and I get that
on YouTube so that's why I'm also here
now let's go to the four hours time
frame what do we have here I have
somebody right now on X a follower
asking me
C removable it is a head and
shoulders I don't trade fixed patterns
with Head and Shoulders okay but who
knows if that is the case it's not going
to be because the head and shoulders but
it's going to be because the market
maker believes that there is enough
liquidity inside this area to come to
the range lows towards this liquidity
pool and then the same price is higher
so is what I'm telling you we lose this
Zone here and yes I'm going to be paying
an ey I'm going to pay attention to this
liquidity pool and the range lows that's
a 6,700 okay if we get to inside this
area then we would also be partially
feeling that um CM Gap here that we have
that if you notice it goes from
6,900 and it goes to 58,4 7
so we would be partially filling that
Gap if we drop to the range LS again
okay something like this perhaps and
could happen it could happen now
remember the CME gaps and this something
I explained in the previous video it's
something that can take even months
before they get filled so don't expect
them to get filled immediately because
that's usually a a big mistake or the
most common mistake uh regarding
gaps especially when a CME Gap is this
big okay because when they are smaller
than yes they tend to get filled
immediately okay for example this one
here you got a very small Gap here those
gaps tend to get filled a straight away
between 80 and 85% of them get filled
within the next week right but when is
this big it can take weeks months years
it doesn't have to be
immediately right so that will be the
next area where I will be looking for
longs if we lose this area
but what I have clear guys is that if
you allow me to go into the daily time
frame let me explain this for you okay
you're going to be able to see this well
um you are inside a range all right you
are inside the range you have here your
range lows you also have here your range
highs and there is an area that is this
jellow doed line that is a strong
resistance
and if you notice here there is
aoid we haven't filed this area inside
this area there is a massive open
interest gap which most of you also know
because many of you have done the course
but uh we have here a massive open
interest Gap and that is basically a big
sign of liquidity okay so DS do I think
that price are going to is going to go
to this area
here this area here of course yes
now I'm expecting it to get there
especially after the 31st of July which
I think is going to be the cat list for
prices to go up that is my reasoning
okay because I'm expecting the fair to
do so also you have to pay attention
that we are about above the daily 50 ma
right above it so um there is a
possibility of price coming here testing
our support
consolidate push higher all right so we
have here another potential strong
support but again if we lose the daily
50a then yes I'm going to the range
flows and that's what I'll be looking
again for Longs because that's what here
and here and here and here all right so
yes possibility of going to the range
lows and bringing prices higher but in
the short term I'm still betting on the
on my
projection that especially today we
should see some kind of upside
okay Works to the downside
prera Thursday reversal day I mean there
are many things that liquidity pool
matching with the 1 hour 50 ma that we
didn't test since Wednesday well since
yesterday 24 hours which is quite a lot
for the 1 hour time frame so I think
that I've said everything that I wanted
to say in this video I'll be updating
you more through X and through telegram
too and also before I go I have to say
that if you you want to access this
indicator that probably many of you are
wondering how to get it then there are
two ways the first way is to become a
student of my course but that's not
possible at the moment because we are
remaking the website the whole month of
July and part of August is going to be
for rebuilding the website because it's
looking a beit old and we want to add
some more functions so that's not
possible perhaps in September we have a
course and the other option is to become
uh well an active Trader using my
referral link on X and then every
month we G access to new Traders
basically to the indicator you receive
an email from x with a form that I
made to collect your trading view
username um yeah you fill the form I see
your trading be username I give you
access and you get it so that's pretty
much everything guys all the links are
in the description the Twitter the
telegram the referral link and that's
all so thank you so much for watching
the video and I'll see you soon